I'll go raise my spirit back welcome to
a new horror game this one is called the
cursed forest
I don't like for assists I don't like
for assists
Wow but I especially like cursed ones so
this should be great
Wow this afternoon August 13 I received
bad news my money back in the city had
aired oh no sir HD this voice doesn't
fit at all the road to the city is
rather lengthy so I decided to take a
shortcut through a place some called
cursed because of such reputation no one
had taken that path for quite some time
but I didn't care all what I can bait
when she gave me a neck hurts my voice
to get as quickly as possible the sky
was unusually clear and the Sun was
shining bright that is until I made a
turn to that cursed place suddenly it
had become so dark that even my
headlights didn't make any difference I
had to drive in total darkness no matter
what then something unusual happen
without any reason my car's electricity
started to go off I heard a strange
noise in the dark human figured appeared
in front of my car I tried to brake to
the side but large control and I ended
up in a ditch and then I fade in it next
thing I know I guess we'll never have no
huh whoa hello all right well I'm
camping all the sudden that's that's
great I love camping goddammit no don't
run away from me candy oh no that was my
last pair of oh how they move oh that's
also hello
I can I can play with up there UI hey
all right here fine alright your mate
what was that you just two queries for
is all right well we're going down this
curtain pile wonderful
oh god this is actually awesome
this one guy did this and he said it was
his first project that's pretty [ __ ]
impressive I don't know if I actually
believe that a little it's really good
so looks like the shining but that it's
been polished a thousand times I like it
except it's cursed I mean I love a curse
everyone is always hating on curse
things what if there was a curse that
would make everything better you don't
know they don't be hitting on the cards
as proud that's something I love the
green Oh God alright so there's a net it
came here maybe there's a chance for us
to live after all bris so you were
panicking there for a while you know
what I never get scared by playing
horror games so you're lucky you're with
me it's gonna be fine
we're all gonna be fine once we're out
of this we will laugh at it and we'll be
like whoa boy remember that time we went
inside a curse for his appearance let's
never ever do that again cuz Plzen sucks
at these things
Oh goddamnit that ain't go hello whoa
whoa whoa what happened here you have to
wipe after you go to the toilet god damn
all right you know what i'ma read you
August 12 1967 tomorrow is today when
everything is going to change I tried to
convince the Morgans to stop what
they're planning but they didn't listen
the things they are going to do with her
daughter are out of this world I don't
understand how parents can agree to do
such art about things they're out of the
man's things are bad back in the day not
really as I expected things didn't go
well what have they done I don't know if
anyone's going to read this but there's
one thing I know for sure but they have
awakened doesn't remind me of what that
good little girl I knew it since she was
five today I heard horrible scream in
the distance I don't think this Hut is
safe anymore I feel like I'm being
watched I need to get all her remains
and all of the ritual stones to repeat
the ritual maybe we will purify the
innocent soul then column labels bear
down I haven't heard from any of my
neighbors for a while it seems that we
all are all going to die maybe we
deserve this fate Oh God
it's actually creepy you know what good
note
far too many times I read notes I gave
me goose pimples but whatever I do how
would you know
far too many times you reading it oh god
[ __ ] me oh [ __ ] um nice this is sound of
a motor
oh god I'm legit [ __ ] freaked out
right now I don't like this
Oh God that note did a good job man
alright let's keep going
usually wanted to read notes I don't
give a [ __ ] but that was [ __ ] creepy
man I don't know what's going on but I
know there's a [ __ ] lady out there
that's gonna [ __ ] kill me
and my imagination starts running and I
know she's gonna do weird stuff with me
I just know I just know wait okay all
right you know what
poor Jeff we're so [ __ ] dead we are
so [ __ ] dead Oh Mike that was a
barrel wasn't it yeah every time you
know what I'm not even making the jokes
anymore I'm just being a [ __ ]
observer of things okay this is serious
business okay it's glowing red there we
all know that glowy red stuff is bad but
let's just go there because I have
nothing else going for me right now pick
a bone what the [ __ ] am I gonna do with
you know what fine hello sorry I just
wanted to high-five I wasn't wanted to
hold someone hand in this game that's
all I wanted I just wanted some goddamn
comfort why would I pick up a random as
bone in a random ass [ __ ] curse
forest that is a terrible idea you have
given me no reason to click the app
except the text I told me to do it
goddamn you persuasive text that's why
this curse you I curse you Oh God
Oh God was this a path here before
they've really nailed the [ __ ] fog
and the trees cuz that is creepy mad and
it reminds you all the forests of Sweden
and I'm really scared of though for us
every time we go camping and I want to
pee oh god I don't wanna pee iswe okay
oh [ __ ] I scarce me okay four is a scare
me the first horror movie I ever saw was
Blair Witch Project
and I've kind of been scarred since then
okay it's not even that scary movie but
buy my mushrooms I mean is that even
mushrooms I don't know who knows these
days about anything in life she can't be
sure I'm all right how good okay Oh more
glowy stuff oh [ __ ] what is happening
there oh god I'm so [ __ ] jumpy right
now Oh God bros hold my hand no I can't
hold this hand thank you
all right so I'm collecting Oh God I'm a
collecting a bunch of bones in a forest
that is oh [ __ ] what was that what was
that what was that what was that what is
happening Oh God
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine there's no there's not even
an beans and I'm [ __ ] terrified what
the [ __ ] okay great times
I love times okay I'm really lost man
really shut up Isles you don't know me
don't judge my outfit okay I wanted to
change things up today God it's a
striped shirt what do you want everyone
wakes drives if not get God you oh [ __ ]
Oh God
okay it says leaves the [ __ ] leave
scare me achievements everywhere all
right we found a road brass hype I'm set
high-five God is that eyes up there like
it's she watching more Sims oh there is
someone up there oh god I thought it was
just clipping textures or some [ __ ] god
damn it read back here now then I could
walk in circles and what if we go here
it's kind of seems like I'm limping
honestly Oh Jeff bloody hell virtus
victim oh my god was at it you have not
collected all and while I'm sorry Jesus
Christ give a man some slack all right
how many do I need mr. Fogg man of death
and suffering oh great you how great you
are
let's check out the [ __ ]
ah wonderful great sound effect hahaha
and we've gone here oh god oh god what
is that we have not gone there I'm not
going there
okay I don't know what how I don't like
what that was
don't wanna close my eyes oh there's the
last item and she's there
oh god she's a fraud I hate frogs
they're so slimy I just want to put them
on I'm on my body and on my armpits and
I want them to like me
very slowly come on I have a weird
fetish oh god what am i doing I'm
swimming I'm swimming in a swamp this is
so bad for me man what is that
oh we're picking out the bone parts I
don't want a clay I just clicked oh god
what was that
oh what's that I'm freaking out right
now oh we gonna have to go in the water
I don't want to go in the water I don't
really don't want to go in order okay go
swim swim now I love swimming our lives
for having well that's that's great
something is drowning me don't touch my
ass it's only my second touch my ass
come on come on come on go in and get up
get up get up get up get up
we're fine we're fine we're fine we just
got a little why don't we take the boat
why not hey all right we got all the
items oh Jesus I took me forever okay
this game is [ __ ] insane I can't
explain it but the [ __ ] atmosphere is
doing it forming all right now we can go
past the creepy troll man that doesn't
like me as well is no creepy troll man
like me it's somewhere a passage open
thank you text that is appearing in the
left corner on my eye oh it's here right
yes yeah yeah oh it just had to be the
creepiest book Oh God okay you know what
we're going to beat send him anyplace
beats here and
oh now Smouse ambien it's great I was
waiting for you Indians oh god oh god
Hades
make her do that new juice in my ass oh
that is really thick juice
I love thick juice you just had to do
that in you [ __ ]
ah we're fine
I'm a man and men don't get scared by
damn trees see nobody someone needs to
fix that that is not safe
is it silo loves silos not gonna go near
you though it's not safe I care about
safety and women and boobs and that's
all I got cuz I'm a man
alright just kidding I care about
feelings and long walks on the beach
volleyball hey it's normal
oh god it's not normal well weird let's
check out this house is creepy out some
other [ __ ] house God Oh God alright
oh god don't copy me what have you done
who did you summon it's not what we
expected my lovely wife is gonna say no
Mary I love your placement gave me for
everything just forgive me actually
that's Mary she's been being pimping it
up it's all right Mary I've got I got
you what do we got here pick up a stone
oh [ __ ] she's out there she saw me why
the one I picked up the lantern is
beyond me and everything in space and oh
god no god I'm so fun
Oh
all right Oh oh great yeah swim in the
[ __ ] water yeah that's the best idea
you ever had in your life
sister game it's just the game games
can't hurt us unless we get a heart
attack so keep your [ __ ] cool and
you'll be fine
all right you're with me great we got
this no problem no problem
Adam random torches in the forest oh god
Beth to swim I'm not okay with this what
was that oh no those arms man don't run
and look into the shadow no runnin what
I'm running but I can't got a god oh god
I don't like this come on come on
please I gotta look back what are you
doing you're so slow my god you're tease
oh [ __ ] stone I haven't met you in a
while Jennifer you working out Wow nice
pecs breath come on come on come on
please let me go let me go she touched
my ass that little ho let me go let me
go I would never hurt your soul I don't
care Oh God I got it works frozen helps
everyone I knew it
Oh got an earthquake what have I done to
deserve this
oh I'm Japanese hot Jennifer oh my god
Jennifer run run run run run run
fake Jennifer I like it ha ha this game
is awesome so unexpected hope you guys
enjoyed this video
now we're gonna dance and have a good
time that probably didn't fit for the
atmosphere a really amazing game IV bros
are enjoying this live it like the dead
and I'll see you in the next one
stay awesome births love you